Hello everybody, hello, hello everybody.
Welcome back.
Welcome back to Dispatch number three.
Finale.
Yeah.
Hello, hello.
Hi, Minto.
Doctor, turn off my mint inhibitors.
What would happen?
Hmm.
What would happen if you turned off your minty inhibitors?
Go full mint.
Extra minty, extra freaky.
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
Oh my gosh, Jordan, thank you.
That was my birthday yesterday.
Going in for a suit fitting tomorrow, so I have something
fresh to wear to Framinto with Love on February 13th, which
will have streaming tickets available, I think.
It will.
I'll be seeing you at the club.
Happy birthday!
Oh my gosh, I'm sorry that I missed it yesterday.
Happy birthday, Jordan!
Jordan!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
And I'll see you there!
Exciting.
Hi, Minto, hi, child.
Hello, Reese.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello, Minto and I, booze like you.
Hope you are doing well today.
My head hurts from whatever thought is stuck in there.
Ooh, my head.
It that big old cake in there, huh?
I know it's in your head.
You're thinking about, you're thinking about big old
buttoxes, a round variety.
A cake that is juicy and moist.
It's stuck in there.
Thinking about, thinking about a squishy buns.
Minto got cake?
I think that's what I'm known for.
I think, I think, I think, My booty...
That's all that I got.
That's all.
Panzwan!
I wanted to say it's my birthday!
Thank you for another wonderful year and hope the next one
is even better.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
How did she know?
How did I know what?
Also, hi, Minto.
Hello.
purple max who got timed out pre-stream because you said
hello labubus
inaccurate i'm drawing that particular cake right now should
i be excited enjoy the final final chapters of dispatchment
i'll be crying in the corner due to the song and story in a
mobile game's newest chapter oh no wait whoa what could it
be what did uh didn't nike get an update or something today
is it that i wonder forbidden boo boo boo who limbus company
ah i don't know anything about limbus company i'll be 100
percent honest V.A.
Occult Club story came out.
Yeah, that came out a couple days ago.
Hello, Mito.
Hello, I-Boo's.
I-Boo's, I-Boo's.
I wanted to ask when you possess someone, does anything
physically change about them?
Like eye color, hair gradient, getting 10 centimeters
shorter, etc.
I don't think so.
Next time I possess somebody, I'll look in the mirror.
Maybe you get to my stunning blue eyes.
Oh, my gosh.
i love like memes of people with like my eye my eyes are a
little they're blue but they're a little darker but like
memes of people with like bright blue eyes are so funny i
hope they get the bakery but no your your body's not gonna
change any at all that would be oh my gosh talk about some
growing pains that'd be so bad That would be terrible.
That would be, like, body horror, I think.
And I don't possess for very long, usually.
So it's like...
I'm sick today from watching you.
It always makes me feel better.
Tachibana, feel better.
Feel better for a bottle for a bottle, chie-a.
Feel better.
Having a great time seeing your choices that you make me do.
Is it okay if I request that you cover Flambé's karaoke song
next time you do karaoke?
karaoke tomorrow.
I could try and learn it.
What was it?
I'm a bitch.
My name's Robert.
Substance, something.
Peepie smile.
Maybe you into newbie, crummy pixel art cake.
I love pixel art!
And cake.
Blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue.
Welcome back.
Oh my gosh.
I've kind of been going crazy on steam right now because did
you guys see that until the 19th it's the steam detective
fest so a bunch of detective games are on sale and i've been
like going through a bunch of stuff like i bought i bought
there's like a whole thing of nancy drew games and i bought
it i bought that and um i bought a couple other things but
um i think my steam is i don't know Why does my Steam...
My Steam thinks of me in a very...
My Steam has...
My Steam has a very interesting profile of me.
Where...
When I click...
Hold on, let me see if it does it this time.
When I clicked the Steam Detective Fest thing...
It would...
The recommended games for me.
Thank you, thank you.
to can you solve the case of why you're so cute jb thank you
also thank you i saw your off stream don't know and i feel
really bad that you felt like you needed to donate so much
but thank you very much i really appreciate it um but uh the
steam kept being like here's some games recommended to you
because it has sexual content in it And it would give me,
like, heavy rain!
It gave me...
Wait, what was it?
Hold on, I'll be fine.
It's not showing up anymore, but it gave me heavy rain.
I know, I remember that one distinctly because I was like,
Huh?
What happens in there?
I don't remember anything.
Any sexy time in heavy rain?
I remember Sean and the origami killer and and Jason Jason
the shower scene oh no oh no oh geez oh yeah I was like they
were like it was it kept being like recommended because you
play games with sexual content in it I'm like, wait, whoa,
whoa.
But yeah, I did get a couple...
There was like, there's one that I wanted to try.
The Seance of Blake Manor.
That one looks cool.
If you guys have any recommendations from some of the other
ones that are in the list.
Oh, this bed we made, I wanted to try that out.
I saw Nimi played it too.
But yeah, so I was just kind of...
I was like, ooh, ooh.
Detective games.
I love mystery games, so...
If you have any recommendations, please, please, please
comment, like the video, subscribe, and comment Detective
Gims that I should check out if I haven't already.
Someone whose number one most watched game on YouTube last
year was Nancy Drew just because of your streams.
This is very good news to me.
Yeah, baby.
I thought about... So, sorry, I bring up Nimi again.
just obsessed with her but um there will be uh times when
i'm gone in march i have a a particularly long longer uh
trip trip to japan and then right after i just got announced
for carrier con so um i will be there and um so it's a bit
of a longer uh trip for me i do plan on bringing my travel
set up so that i can stream when i can but similarly to how
When Nimi went on vacation and she did Outer Wilds
playthrough, I was like thinking maybe I could do Nancy
Drew.
And maybe I could have like a Nancy Drew game that I
complete or something as a let's play in between times that
I can stream.
So I plan on streaming, but it just won't be so much.
But I will at least have that kind of.
It's a busy...
It's a busy next couple of months for me, guys.
Will you be seeing Vicky?
I will!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pre-recorded like you mean.
Mm-hmm, it would have to be.
Yeah.
Been a minute, boss, and static about the Carrier Con
announcement!
Catch my fellow Ibuzon deck!
Yeah!
Hopefully some will see the Ace Combat A-Type.
Oh my gosh!
I can't wait to go on the ship and roleplay.
Ace Combat 8.
I'm so excited.
Minto Auto Feeder.
Here you go.
Here's your Nancy and Drew for today.
Mint Boo.
Duck Boo.
Duckie.
Booby.
Yeah.
We're gonna.
The new travel setup looks so cool.
Thank you.
For those that didn't see.
I posted.
I got a mini piece.
Okay.
So, backing up a little bit.
I've been using a mini PC for, like, certain games.
Like, I used it for Harvester.
I used it for...
One shot.
There was one more, though.
Ha, da, ka.
Before we get to the game, a couple of annoying questions.
Any plans on checking out the new block game?
High Tail.
It's all the rage now.
I haven't heard of that.
And two, thoughts on Orbology.
Orb.
But Druids, yes, thank you.
Druids.
I will check out New Block Game.
I have not heard of it, though.
It's basically Minecraft 2.
You haven't heard about it?
Mm-mm.
I'll check it out.
I love Minecraft.
In Minecraft 2, maybe.
At the risk of backseating, I'm turning into VOD Squad.
Have fun, everyone.
I don't mind.
I honestly don't mind if people try to backseat and try to
give advice.
I think, you know, this is my opinion.
Obviously, and this is just my, like I said, it's my
opinion, not every streamer is going to think the same way.
I don't mind if people are trying to help.
i think it's up to the streamer's discretion whether they
want to follow that or not like in this for example in like
a game like this like i could i could you know i could poll
you guys for every decision each time um and say okay what's
the majority all right we'll do that or i could you know um
another time i i think probably the only time that back
sitting most annoys me is if I'm like trying to solve a
puzzle and if I don't get it within the first five seconds
if somebody like goes into the chat and spoils it and I'm
you know I can like not look at chat for things like that
but I also just kind of enjoy your guys's company so I I
can't help it I just look over sometimes I think that's uh
the most annoying thing for me and I guess the other but I
think it's because I'm usually getting frustrated at a game
is like if I'm playing like a fighting like a game with
combat and I'm like oh my gosh I can't get this thing I
don't know how to do it and people are like trying to
explain and I'm like I'm trying but that's just because I'm
frustrated in the moment it's not even like a it's like you
guys are just trying to help but I'm like as a viewer I
don't mind backseating but people complaining about you not
listening to them it's kind of irritating i get that too you
know it's okay to just turn off chat and enjoy the ride as
well free tuber do this instead why yeah
i think with these kinds of games like the story driven uh
choose your own adventure types a lot of people just get so
enthusiastic they're just like i played this game and when i
played it choices I picked mean you have a really really fun
time and so you'll have a really really fun time if you
choose the same exact choices that I made so just cater to
my choices you know what I mean or thank you so much for the
five gift thank you um but uh you know um yeah that's just
uh you know accidents no sorry i was just thinking about it
today because you know i i understand that people get really
excited and uh i i obviously do have to put my foot down
sometimes and be like hey hey you guys happy to see you this
project today thank you gopoo i actually haven't played it
but the game return of the oberdin i have played that wide
oh my gosh it's really it's really interesting It's really
fine.
It's difficult, though.
That's a tough game.
That's a really, really tough game.
It's really cool, though.
It's very, very cool.
Um, but yeah.
You should put your foot down more often, Minto.
Yeah, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna put my foot down.
And then I'm gonna spit on the person on the ground.
to me yeah
I'll say stay down stay down I hear more streamers should
put their foot down more often I think people a lot of
streamers get very scared of of how to say just like I guess
offending people not offending just like scaring off their
audience you know what i mean yeah the backlash i think a
lot of people get freaked out about it um because you know
if you're getting frustrated about something that's
happening it's very easy to lose your cool lose your temper
about it and you know be like i said this i said stop it and
it comes out the wrong way and then people are like ew
terrible streamer
But you're a ghost.
What are you going to put your foot down on?
I guess you would...
Would you feel it?
I would concentrate...
Okay.
I would concentrate all my spiritual energy into my leg.
And it might be a little silly because I would become
literally like a ball of energy with one really beefy leg.
And then you would feel it.
It would be...
Yeah, I would look like Ibu, but with a really big, little
beefy leg.
Because all of my spiritual energy, I would lose the ability
to, like, conjure up a form, as you see me now.
Being a ghost is so difficult, you guys.
You don't understand.
Or just write that down.
I have the sudden urge to tell you what to do.
Don't boss me around.
You're not my ma'am.
Just so you can give her the super time.
It's important to set boundaries.
Yeah, I think I, I think, well, I think.
I don't know.
Legs.
Except leg.
Because it'd be one leg.
Because I'm just putting my foot down.
She got the cake and the game.
I think I'll have a leg of beef for dinner.
White screen waiting room.
Chat, we need to have a talk.
Wait, I'm confused.
What's it about?
Wait, what are we talking about?
Huh?
Am I getting grounded?
Wait, what's happening?
What do we have to talk about?
Serious chat?
with talk wait serious talks with chat every day is leg day
minto uh not not not usually okay sometimes i don't even
conjure any legs i just kind of like let it happen i just
have like little wispy bottom you can't see it anyway
announcement parentheses yep It's what it's exactly what you
think about what you're thinking Putting this stream on for
sleep noise is dangerous because I'm invested in this story
But I'll try to sleep have a great stream binto good night
song kid I'll try not to yell or scream or cry or shout or
exclaim or
Please do all of those things Scream every word.
Today I'm taking up a heavy metal.
You're absolutely not Orbital Vagabond, I believe you.
Put your foot down.
If I get out of hand, you can kick me in the butt.
In fact, you can just wedge it up there.
Really teach me a lesson.
Put me in my place.
No ulterior motive.
Okay.
Hanaka-saku!
Thank you so much for the fight!
Get the...
Scream and yell more!
Hello!
Shall we get into it though?
Shall we beat the game?
Shall we complete the game?
I like how the... Wait, what happened to the...
What happened to the vending machine?
Oh no!
Wait, oh before then, let's go over our choice stats as we
did before.
So we added Water Boy to our team.
And we did have dinner with Blonde Blazer, except right
there she's Bruna.
It's a little misleading.
We did throw spaghetti because it's the more delicious
choice.
uh we warned her about her dress and she really appreciated
it because she went on a date with us um we didn't we did
not uh tell him about kissing blonde blazer i thought he was
gonna kill me i thought he was gonna murder me but
apparently if i told him it would just be yaoi oh well um we
adopted the baby kaiju um we failed the brain teaser that
was my fault i did i so someone in the comment i got a
comment on last stream they were like yeah um all of the
things were like games that telltale games have made like
the wolf among us isn't that what it's called and then the
walking dead i was like i for some reason i didn't even
think that it was like an opposite because i think it was
like the living walk or something i don't know i was like oh
yeah it's like wolf amogus amogus i was like oh my gosh i
didn't even realize that they're like opposites of the title
names i just thought it was like a silly version of the
title just not the actual like walking dead or something
like that so wolf inside us no i thought just like random
synonyms of the titles me too that's why i was like oh shoot
oh well that's okay where our set uh And I performed better
than 40% of players in today's shift.
Wait, does that mean I'm good?
I don't understand statistics.
I failed that class.
So here we...
You with 20% of players told the Z-Team you were just
Robert.
Oh my gosh, I can't wait.
I can't wait for the drama to come from this.
Ooh, everybody was so mad that I wasn't honest.
But can you...
Oh my gosh, everybody was so shocked.
to hear that we were just that we were mecca man at the
party and they were like oh and it's gonna be oh my god it's
gonna be drama and then we went on a second date with amandy
which that hasn't happened yet so um i would kill shroud and
then just um my most sent hero was invisible and physical
and then episode six we were oh yeah i was ready to send
them in because i have confidence And I have confidence in
my dispatch abilities.
But clearly, nobody else does.
Maybe I shouldn't have said that because it went against
blonde blazer.
It was like more siding with Envisagal.
But I think I'm just that good.
Bunch of non-believers.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Going against your girlfriend.
I don't are we officially dating like are we going out I
thought we were just testing the waters I mean we did kiss
if you kiss someone does that mean you're dating how does it
work you literally kissed in the sky no yes what if in my
brain if I kiss somebody if then I'm dating them my brain
maybe wait you're practically married i think so too i think
we should start uh we should open up a joint bank account i
think it's time i think we're at that point and you know it
doesn't mean dating but you do get pregnant scary ask for a
prenup i think she has more money than I do.
I think she would want the prenup.
Actually, I think we're broke.
um, I think she would want the prenup.
Uh, yeah.
Imagine blonde blazer, but MGS 3 Eva outfit.
I like that.
like that a lot.
I don't know why I was worried about missing anything while
having dinner at 7.
I should have known my Oshie is the app master 5000.
Wait a second.
I'm going, I'm, I'm, we're going over my choices right now.
I'm, I'm playing the game.
Ish.
We're discussing the game.
We're giving a recap of the game.
I...
This is the game!
Yeah, we're talking strats.
I'm talking mad strats.
I'm talking everything that will happen, Lunderstomp.
Welcome back.
Thank you!
We did help in Visigal.
And then we danced with Blonde Blazer and it was great.
Wow.
what does that mean I'm getting sent codes what do they mean
thank you for the super chat
these are just how good I am at the game I was a bard spread
my code and my most sent hero was water boy and my most
successful hero was water boy yeah yeah everybody's just
says water boy is useless has never seen my team baby i
molded him sculpted him i i zeroed a hero he is the greatest
of all time goater boy okay now let's play the game how are
the comics has anyone read the comics of this are they any
good art of this oh that's the art and then they're okay
extra lore thanks for answering my question earlier I was
imagining the possession traits showing up while possessing
but disappear after you leave I think that would really like
not be good for you I think I imagine it would be like a
motion sick Disneyness
what's that thing vertigo zero to hero not water goat has
always was always always him you're true you're so right
that's so true that's so true characters back stories oh
that's fine okay so now we're on episode seven seven and
eight let's do it retrospective of an accident or injury
should occur on the job it is extremely important for you to
notify your manager or hr promptly no matter how minor the
incident may seem sdn employee handbook page 37 The last
episode ended on quite the sad cliffhanger, so let's see.
Let's see how it goes this time.
Is Grandpa okay?
I hope so.
Keep up.
Is that crying?
Uh oh.
I'm too old to be crying.
oh fuck off no you're not i cry all the time really when
okay it's a flashback when i was your age i cried for weeks
when the raiders left la yeah that's totally the same as my
dad never being home whoa motherfucker language oh he's
always been this way and it was the same my pops had season
oh he's so dead isn't he oh we're getting a flashback he's
so dead yeah When they moved, I was crying like a little
bitch, too.
Are you saying I'm crying like a bitch?
Yes, bitch.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
Jesse, that's where he learned this language.
Your dad gave me a hundred, and I gotta break the shit
anyway.
He pays you?
To be around your crying bitch ass?
Fuck yeah, he pays me.
Oh my god, language, though.
Now, come on, whatever you want.
Just make it less than $20.
Twinkies!
Wait, I should have said a cigar.
Can I get a cigar?
twinkie hey because you're crying you can have two ah that
could have had two cigars no shit kid i was joking keep up
oh he is way too fast did he ever realize that he was like
accelerated aging because of his stuff or until it was like
too late i wonder you happy now yeah well yeah you can be
sad like not until it's too late so stinky I didn't realize
you two were that close that it went back that far no he's
alive he's not well he's uh I was lost for a while I was
obsessed with making the mecha man thing work extreme focus
you know one step in of the other.
I thought it was going to cut to a funeral.
I'm not going to lie.
I didn't know where I was.
I'm sorry.
Chase had only babysit nights when dad had to deal with
something big.
Working late, he called him.
I was fine being alone, but I'd still ask to have him wash
me because I could guilt trip him into buying me shut.
He never said no.
What if I asked for a cigar?
What do you have said no?
I made him run a lot back then right so maybe one less door
run for bitch-ass Robert and he wouldn't be stuck in here
that's what you're saying right I mean it was but now that
you put it like that he'd buy him he gets whatever you
choose that's crazy here pending the investigation in
Visigal suspended obviously but I think you should consider
cutting her from the team I'm not saying you should I'm just
saying you should consider it I'll get back to you I really
don't want to think about it right now that's fair of course
yeah it's just I can't help but think that we've already cut
a hero for far less we had to send a message that's kind of
my point
and better we can cut her vending machine whatever I want
whatever I want he's so fucking proud of the man you've
become he told me that oh oh I wanted a like princess
carried me.
What?
I mean, I guess he just, like, his dad's passing was, like,
not so long ago, so.
Twinkies!
See, it's a good thing we picked the Twinkies.
This vending machine wouldn't have beer or cigars in it.
Oh, I think he's about to break the vending machine.
Okay, I think I understand why it's broken, though.
does that work I think he's got to catch on fire right you
okay bud it's just I'm just mad yeah I'm a little mad too I
can't it's not fair it does it works and Visigal was the one
who and then Chase shouldn't have hmm
He's such a good boy.
You think he did the right thing?
I mean, I don't.
It seems very not clear.
Or unclear.
I don't know, man.
You know, Waterboy, I wish I had an answer for you.
I just...
In this case, I really don't know.
He is a hero.
He did his hero thing.
But...
case no point oh yeah feel better kind of I'll clean it up I
think more people were like you know he just took so many
things a lot of people were like you know really I guess
they really were like close to chase so it's it just is hard
that because she disobeyed orders main takeaways are that he
ended up getting hurt so we're a person down the shift and
that chase is in the infirmary and he's in pretty rough
shape despite his disposition it's like full of water just
don't tell him i told you that
helps when i'm feeling bad we're fortunate to have that
opportunity not the vague chase never took for granted so
let's get to work okay let's get to work oh my god it's
raining it's so sad wait who do i have that can upgrade oh
my gosh prism okay let's go um Let's go.
Let's go intellect.
She's gone.
Yeah, she's just gone.
Rare rain in LA.
I think the last time I went to LA, it was raining.
And it was, I remember, because it was flooding.
And Nimi would be like, are we going to be okay?
Are we going to be able to get through this street?
It's flooding.
Or we would see like a sign for a street that was closed.
And she's like, what if it flooded?
What if there was...
It's so funny.
Let's see.
I don't remember what I was doing for...
Malevolah is like all over the place.
I haven't really been focusing on her.
The music is so sad and everything.
Oh my goodness.
Mobility, maybe?
Yeah.
We'll just make her all around.
She's like a circle at this point.
It's my bad.
You said she was an all-rounder.
I did say that?
Okay, cool.
Well, I meant it.
Intellect.
He's the smartest guy ever.
Okay.
I think...
We haven't unlocked Flambé's second...
We haven't even gotten punch-ups first.
I haven't gotten Prism's second.
Or Malev...
No, we did get Malevula.
Yeah, because I remember...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then Golem we have.
And Coupe.
We have.
Waterboy.
Okay.
Cool.
Went a hint?
Since it's...
maybe what I only probably get to dispatch like max four
more times maybe so
yeah you can give a hint how to get punch up since we're
like basically at the end game punch up needs to fail a call
to access it no stinking way I'm just too good at the game
punch up needs to get hurt I'm too good at the game oh my
I'm too good at the game.
That's why I haven't unlocked it.
SMAH.
We've been fucked on a beached whales off the coast.
Could really use some help getting them back in the ocean.
When a whale is beached, that's like it for them, no?
Hall a dozen 25-ton whales back into the...
Move them as fast as possible before the crowd gathers.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, we do have mobility now with Coupe, so...
Yeah, they do explode.
Like, they kind of, like, the gases inside build up, and,
like, you have to, they, like...
It has to all release.
Yeah.
Music is so dramatic.
Second is mobility.
Well...
Can I, like... I wish I could, like...
Oh, wait!
Guys, oh, well, I guess he doesn't really, he doesn't like
expand the rush, you know what I mean?
Let's just do it.
Let's just do the two of them.
It's fine.
That's, that's a hundred percent.
We'll get it, most likely.
Eat a little, eat a little, eat a little.
Upchuk's rugby team lost, and he's throwing a very toxic
tantrum.
Send one and gamble?
Yeah.
Acid vomit villain Upchuk is using the rain to rain terror
on civilians.
Use necessary force.
We could send these too.
Fucking useless.
We useless!
That would you just send?
Well, if they lose, then that's even better too.
I should have sent him solo actually now that I think about
it.
Beach just means they're stuck dead or alive.
Oh, okay, okay.
I'm too good at the game.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Oh, hello?
Oh, I figured that's what it would do.
Okay.
We don't know yet.
So being skilled and beautiful.
I know.
Goodness.
Alright.
What is it?
Left, right, right, left.
Left, right, right.
Come here.
How close you need to be.
Okay.
La la la la la la la la la la la.
It's not even like music.
It's like ambience.
It's so sad.
Runaway car.
Stop the runaway car before it crashes.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
I think if I chose either of these, maybe the Endure.
Okay, hold on.
Because it's an 8.
I know the last one would be a win, but if we're trying to
get punch-ups it could be like it could be enduring is like
a 10 you know what I mean and we're at 8 I
should have just sent him solo should have I we could try
another call yeah we'll win this one we'll win this one
because we have an easy win that's fine yeah I failed the
next one okay I'll send him for whatever we it.
Doesn't matter.
I'll let him rest up and then send him over.
I think it'll be okay.
Yeah.
Oh, homest.
One, um, skill point.
We're gonna put more vigor into you.
Flambé, we're gonna put more.
I think because I don't have... Wait, who else?
I don't... I only have coupé now for mobility, so we're
going to add more mobility to him.
One inch king.
If it could be zero, I'd do it.
He's dumb as rocks.
I mean, nah.
Wow.
Slow day, huh?
Oh, and nobody's talking either.
It's a little unnerving.
Hello?
Are you okay?
Oh, Golem's shit face.
I think he's about to piss mud on the high school.
Oh, no.
Yeah, you know, I saw him pulling over a beer truck earlier.
I did think that was weird.
Come on, buddy.
Spit it out.
I'm not vomiting this shift.
You are...
Golem, I get it.
I want to get shit face right now more than anything, but
we've got a job to do.
And I need all of you to do it.
just hang in there until the end of the shift after that you
can do whatever the fuck you want
cool can someone please go get golem before he does more
property damage oh oh little guy big guy actually save golem
from himself and carry him back to stn it's all you buddy if
there's no one else it's all you let's send our smallest guy
to get our biggest guy.
Wait, where'd my mouse go?
Oh, there's...
Okay, so we've got a super down here who controls bugs.
Apparently they have beef with one of our farmers using
pesticides.
Watch him clear it.
That'd be crazy.
Take down the bug-controlling assailant.
Save the farmer being attacked by the bees.
I feel like Flambe can handle this.
Honestly, we can't really...
Well, I guess we could send Waterboy to The bees!
I think he's got this.
Wait, the fucking rain.
Flang's a bitch, you can't see shit.
The streets turned into a goddamn slip and slide.
I fucking love slip and slide, bro.
I haven't seen it come down this bad and wild.
Oh, I can't wait.
If he...
I like it.
It feels right for today.
Fucking cool it, emo boy.
I'm the best Hulk I could muster.
I'm too good at the game!
Sonny's...
7%!
No!
Oh my god.
Oh!
Streamer luck, I guess so.
Oh, shoot.
I'm gonna give him some more charisma too.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah, we only have, like, prism and well, actually,
We have Waterboy Coupe.
We have a lot on Int.
Let's do more vigor, then.
Keep going.
Your luck is literally against all odds.
Yes, yes.
Hey, the Bone Zone pissed off the wrong gang, and they're
holding him hostage.
Listen, I know he sucks, but he writes my checks.
Can you please just rescue him?
I send punch up she can't keep getting away with this Morgan
welcome to membership thank you all right we're gonna send
punch up this time or what just going to confirm one of your
z team heroes for our interview this afternoon to discuss
the phoenix program oh prism would be perfect yeah we're
good guys now hello uh is this thing working let's oh sorry
what's happening hello what are you doing wait oh just
kidding i sent you out um oh this is flight school okay we
can send coupe all right this is punch up wait oh oh i'm
short i'm running late to the airport perfect it's oh wait
it's the mayor's assistant oh yeah perfect we don't need to
be good at this one This is not like an emergency.
Okay.
Rescue bone zone from villains.
Break through the barricades.
Hmm.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Yippee!
Okay, and then he heals.
So good.
Wait, what happened here?
angle should we use um overhyped the team overhyped the team
oh yeah because facts would be stat would be smart so oh
shoot oopsy figures haters no what the heck is this wait
what are these uh play it safe go all out okay listen we
need to play I don't want anyone else getting hurt.
Red rings coordinating strikes across torrents.
Looks like they're hitting the port next.
Recon only.
Find out what they're up to.
Don't be seen.
So you gotta be, uh, you could be fat.
Oh, wait.
If I did the two of them, it would be too much.
Hold on.
What's, uh, go all out?
Now's our chance to get payback.
Or chase.
Bring the fight.
Make them pay.
Fire and water.
I know.
wait this actually might work this actually might work i
think this will work fine i'll fucking say it water voice
solo he could do it he could do it for sure yay coupe can
now fly awesome why even not talking about it won't make it
go away okay okay insta win if he dies he'll be taken care
of that i can promise how do you know i just did trust me
okay if he did this
okay yay he failed wait nothing happened this fucking rain
is flooding our neighborhood we need this water gone maybe
he does need to get injured instead of rather just failing i
saw me some people say that he just needs to fail and that
some people say he needs to get injured Okay.
Dang.
Oh, well.
Investigate what could be causing flooding.
Oh, everybody is like...
We have nobody.
We have Prism.
Prism can go all on our lonesome.
Move quickly?
Oh.
Wait a second.
Hero training helps me keep my mind off of things.
I really think it can help the team too.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Let's pull somebody out.
of resting, we'll pull out Clupé.
Okay.
Back to it.
There we go.
Beep, beep, beep.
Oh, wait.
I need to do a training then.
We could do Flambé.
Oh, that was close.
Prism Second is really good.
What was Prism Second?
I don't even remember.
Wait, hold on.
Uh, powers.
Oh, I don't have it yet.
That's why.
I don't have it yet.
Oh, the duplicate.
Yeah, I was like, wait.
I don't even have it yet.
There's a mass pile up in the Tanger caught fire.
Rescue the trapped civilians and cars.
The fire's growing despite the rain.
Put it out quick.
I think this is a golem solo.
Maybe not.
He thought he'd be quicker.
Let's do Disrupted.
Punch up this time.
You guys are probably right.
Examine the store.
We can do...
Yeah, we can do this one.
He's too slow.
Noise.
Flood under control.
Okay, I have so many stats.
need to like start giving to people oh my gosh water boy
you're getting some more vigor and wait i didn't i didn't
confirm there we go coupe you're gonna get oh no no no no no
more smarts more intellect train prism that's what i want to
do yeah and then flambé i thought maybe flambé too i don't
have his second power either Maybe Flambe.
Waterboy's stats look like Batman's symbol.
It does.
That's how you call him.
Our all-rounder, you're going to get more vigor.
Actually, more mobility.
I guess it's fine.
And Flambe.
I am the water.
I am the one who knocks.
I am the danger.
I am the one who drinks water.
It doesn't really work.
It doesn't work.
Never mind.
Ignore.
It's awkward now.
You tried.
I did.
Mobility.
I feel like we need a little bit more mobility in here.
It's our rooms, but yeah?
Yeah, confirmed it this morning.
We're all good.
Okay.
And we don't have enough.
We do have...
Okay, here we go.
Confirmed.
Let's just do his.
I don't want to lose it.
Good evening, Minto and Wisps.
Sps.
Are you happy to be here?
Hello!
Alright, let's see what we got.
Comet.
After a success, Flambé also reduces call completion and
travel time.
Yo, my name is Minto, and I have a hint of where the secret
treasure is, but you'll never guess where it is, because I
hid it real good.
And how
I can think of his food, but it doesn't, because it has to,
but it doesn't rhyme.
I hit it real good, but you'd have to knock on wood to find
where it's at, because I only told my cat.
You'll never find it.
My treasure.
A treasure is hidden in my pillow.
Did you guys ever, like, hide stuff under your pillow when
you were, like, trying to hide it before?
You weren't supposed to say...
Oops.
My bad.
Comment, after a success, Flambé also reduces call
completion and travel.
time after two successes flambe fails a third wait what oh
if after two successes he fails a third he is downed oh my
gosh ben drowned succeeding twice will set flambe's combat
and mobility to max and removes rest time after a fail
flambe's stats drop to one oh i should not have trained this
guy
You've met with a terrible fit, haven't you?
Oh my god!
Just don't fail, for real.
You'll have to hide it under another pillow.
I think I'll do comet because...
It's only after one success.
This one, it has to be two successes.
But it removes rest time.
After a fail, his stats drop to one.
That's so risky.
DeviCard, thank you so much for that gifted.
Or maybe Supernova is better.
Because then at least he's still in.
His combat and mobility are already maxed out.
No.
Oh, wait.
I didn't think so.
No.
It just gives the impression that it is.
But they're far from.
I don't know why it's showing up like that.
That's confusing.
Call...
Wait.
This one removes rest time.
That's kind of huge.
I think I'll go with supernova.
Wah!
He already flies.
That has nothing to do with rest time.
Oh No, we were so close Oh, no, go home Lucy Oh, well, okay
Good shift all things considered See you tomorrow Hopefully
with some good news Wait, we only I thought it was
lunchtime.
We only did one I know we were so stinking close Imagine
It's so sad Babe Oh he's in his chair No Who's in there?
Oh
The girls are fighting What's happening now?
Damn You weren't part of the uh what are y'all looking at
she's just got a little yeah oh um cheers lad good looking
out who is paying for this okay who's gonna pay for this
i'll pay i'm the one that caused the damage yeah i'll pay
i'm the one that kicked you oh okay cool now that we've got
all of the details clear why that's just a difference
face he had every right to punt me through the wall right
it's a door and I doubt you were actually in his face more
like ankle easier to kick what the fuck is going on we want
her out we voted it was nearly unanimous she shouldn't have
done what she did I think she should go sir I thought they
would want her to stay Oh, dang.
Who wants her to stay?
Just me.
Oh, Gollum!
But the team is more important than any one of us, so.
Oh, Gollum.
I won't stand in the way.
You could have led with that.
We heard about the suspension bullshit.
It ain't enough, Robert.
Not for what she did.
To put everything we've been building at risk, and for what?
I like the bitch, but she gotta go.
And by go, we mean cut, just like you cut Sonar.
No one here wants to say it's also her.
But that's what it is.
Look, I probably don't say this enough.
I want them to lie, you know what, I get it.
But I'm proud of all of you.
How far you've come.
A few months ago, you wouldn't have been in a room like this
discussing the needs of the Z team.
And if you did, there would be a lot more than one broken
door.
So, I'm not putting all of that at risk for one person who
can't keep up.
I've done my best to salvage things and work with her, but
as you know, this isn't the first time a Visigal has put us
at risk.
It's not that I didn't like her.
It's just business, baby.
It'll be the last.
I'll let Blazer know of your decision.
And I'll let her know.
I support it.
Oh, Gollum, I'm so sorry.
Aww.
She was here.
She's holding her breath this entire time.
Busy?
Sorry, I can come back.
Why?
First time we met you were in your underwear.
fitting right last time you see me that I'd be in mine I
heard everything you don't have to double fire me okay I'm
going you gave me no choice well you gave me no choice you
fired yourself when you went after the pulse I tried my best
really and I think I tried the most with you but it wasn't
enough I wasn't enough which is why this this is on me okay
sounds like a breakup i guess if you like go pursue her it
doesn't way more of a breakup they're right i don't deserve
anyone's forgiveness anyone's health anyone's love because i
can never repay it nothing i do will ever make up for what
i've already done to you i'd hope getting the astral pulse
back would help i don't think the I couldn't even do that.
You're being a little dramatic.
You don't owe anyone anything, okay?
Least of all me.
I was there that night.
What are you saying?
Oh.
I never ran with Cruz.
Always did my own thing, but my ass...
I was gonna say he's shocked by our booba.
They had an augment that could increase my lung capacity.
Only catches I'd have to work for them, paying down for
years.
Oh, she was there!
Oh!
The black bars.
They're so funny.
Then one day Shroud came to me and said, I could have the
whole time cleared if I was able to do one thing.
Place a bomb on the back of my command undetected.
Put the bomb!
But
how do you not get...
Good news, buddy.
I mean, am I so...
I mean, that's...
I could be mad at her, but like...
The villain does a villain thing.
She changed, oh, she decided that she wanted to be good
after.
I mean, it's so bad, but...
I quit the moment I placed it i walked out before it even
blew she oh so she just wanted her debt cleared and then she
left my augments conveniently stopped working so i signed up
for the phoenix program the next day which gave me the
chance to fuck your life up twice well what i like i said i
well i forgive you so there we fucking chill out now You
can't fucking forgive me?
You haven't even, like, processed what's going on.
You did villain shit while you were...
That's exactly what I just said!
That's the same things that you directed at me?
No.
That's what I just said.
That's in the past.
You're not the same person that was there that night,
neither am I.
That's sweet.
Maybe I'm Robert.
All I wanted from this was for people to look at me the same
way to eat.
You look at Blazer.
Even if it was just once, you know?
Instead, they've always seen me how you see me right now.
And what was that?
Like I'm incapable of good.
I think in this situation, it's not that she's...
We're not cutting her because she's incapable of being good.
She has to understand that she's being cut because...
She...
She made this stupid decision.
Like, I think anybody would get fired from a job for that.
My Oshiminto Robertson III.
She's just a loose can And yeah, like she knew She has to
learn to be like A little more, you know Yeah, impulsive is
a good way to put it Yeah, yeah, yeah
She tried to help you though Yeah, but like Some people try
to help and it ends up Making things worse Uh oh
Oh Team water boy So true.
I feel like...
Sorry, never mind.
I don't know.
Oh!
I didn't even notice that there was a thing down there.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even notice that there was a decision.
Oops.
But I don't think it's our... it's up to us to reveal his
identity.
I would have picked Invisigirl anyway, because I don't think
it's up to us to reveal that.
That's him.
Sorry.
I was like reading her text and how she writes.
Yeah, I'm feeling like...
I hope they all die.
I'm serious.
Beard guy.
Any dumbass walking into a trap that fucking stupid should
have to plug pulls right now.
Just pillows over faces.
Oh man, have you seen what the poison does to their faces?
They get all red and puffy.
Ooh.
Ooh!
God damn.
All right.
I'm just a fucking bitch.
I'm sorry.
It's my fault.
Um, I've been distracted.
Give me another drink.
They smashed mine.
Sure.
Malevolent best girl.
You seem turd.
Oh, fuck.
I know what's going on.
You'd probably lost someone there.
That's why he's been staring at that shit all night.
Who are?
Who is this guy?
oh my god this one's on me beard guy his beard guy
thank you we're doing shots together even oh that was the
cleanest pour I've ever seen ever free beer oh my uh oh
don't say anything about my girl.
I will have to defend her honor.
Invisibich.
Fucking traitor.
I won't be bad anymore.
Cheers, fellas.
To the fucking dream.
To five minutes with the tightest ass in all of L.A.
County.
Don't say that who that- Motorboat an ass?
Probably not, right?
You probably could, right?
The one who had that upper butthole.
What's up?
You don't like asses.
Glash him!
Oh!
I thought I was gonna pour it on him.
Now as far as that was gonna take you.
Good on you, Kate.
You replaced that dream.
That's what glassing means.
I learned.
I respect her.
Blazer.
Real fucking superhero.
Uh-oh.
He got the juice.
The red juice.
Everybody's got the juice.
Tune to blow some fucker's brains out.
Non-slip mats are a must.
Uh-oh.
Need some for the hideout.
Feel silly calling it a hideout.
Is beard guy shroud?
Can you take care of him for me?
Obviously, you two don't need an introduction.
I've been waiting for this.
No way!
So dark!
Chase.
Your little team.
You're a little team of turning coats.
You think you can beat the bad by being good.
Oh.
But there's no solving human nature.
This is MGS3 torture sin happening.
Stop evil.
Whoa.
All you can do is control.
it wait is it actually is this was your father's gun kept it
in his locker fully loaded six shots i couldn't have
predicted i'd use it to kill him the first bullet raised his
shoulder and adjusted Spike.
Sick shot.
I'm sorry.
I'm listening.
I was lying on the floor, eyes full of fear, when I put the
fourth through his face.
Oh my god.
A bit of a waste to put the fifth or that idiot's skull, but
I wanted to make sure it worked after all these years.
Sorry.
Your father was the last person to touch this blood.
And now, there's a 16 and a half percent chance that touches
you next.
Your invisible girlfriend Hey, hey, hey, I have another
girlfriend.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh, she...
Mega Man.
Heroes are the past.
Spit!
With the pulse, I'll control this city and restore balance.
Oh, bro.
This is why I hate luck.
Runs out.
Never punished!
It's fine.
Had it, why did I let you string me up like a fucking
pinata?
She didn't get the pulse.
She did, but...
Didn't she get taken from her?
You actually believe that.
Show him.
He really sounds like Jesse here.
Invisibitch has the pulse.
She had it, but I thought it was taken from her.
What I don't know is why she didn't give it.
it to you.
She played you too.
You're I am thinking she's working with you, but she's
fucking us both.
She doesn't want us to be Mecha Man?
She didn't take it for you.
Mecha Man, Mecha Man!
Mecha Man!
It's okay.
She fooled me too.
This is a little...
Oh my god, she's so awesome.
A blonde laser.
I hired the bartender, but I can still get you something to
drink.
No, thank you.
Oh, the way she walked in.
What do I owe the pleasure?
I'm here for him.
Fired, I know.
In five minutes, this bar will be surrounded by SDN agents,
heroes, and whoever else you in your ring have pissed off
recently, which happens to be every gang in Los Angeles.
Now, if you...
Oh, shit.
Do not disrespect one of the last true heroes.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, my God.
Wait, I kind of love Shroud.
Sorry about that.
If they weren't shit, you wouldn't have cut them.
You were saying...
I can see I'm outnumbered.
That eventually I would fall.
But by my read...
I'm taking a lot of you with me.
She's so cool!
So all of you can leave now.
I think we picked right, guys.
Or half of you can die here.
No, that's a fucking superhero.
Chills.
Top notch.
You made them nervous.
Okay, we're out of here.
Take your piss-soaked pants out the back, please.
Don't want to tempt this tiger.
Now's not our time, Blazer.
But it's coming sooner than you think.
And by my calculations, it was closer to 32%.
But half sounds better.
I think I'm obsessed with him.
Oh, my God!
Urm, actually.
I can't believe you found me.
How do you find me?
Yeah.
I tracked your phone.
Sorry.
She's obsessed with me, too.
I'll never forgive you.
She's obsessed with me.
Oh, it's Matt Mercer.
Oh, my God.
He kills it.
Don't worry.
I've got you.
Oh, my God.
It's the Princess Carrie that I always wanted.
Yippee!
He really tenderized you.
Yeah, I could use someone to kiss my boo-boos.
Yeah.
I saw the footage.
What if it was doctored?
why wouldn't she tell you if she has it I don't understand
what she would want it for unless she's planning something
but I don't know if it's good or bad is it the mask she's
planning something shut up just don't know what stop stop
calling me out I don't welcome the membership thank you
you're probably right just need a sit here for like a few
weeks then they'll be right as rain take your time i don't
know how you're conscious see when uh oh my gosh he's
basically it's easier to get used to he's like he's
basically a snake that goes for physical and emotional
really is nice up here thank you oh don't remember 50 times
you were muttering it the whole flight you should know I was
going to take you to the actual Hollywood sign not as sturdy
as you uh-oh why
why is everything just exploding oh that's not good oh oh
uh-oh not on TV oh the children
It's normal LA Thursday.
Maybe you should have taken out most of them.
Well, I guess...
I believe her 50%.
You're not leaving me here again.
How did he get down before?
I hope the peppermint club is safe.
I'll make sure of it.
was such a short episode oh my gosh the ladder oh was there
one he jumped he did a flip and it negated all damage the
music in this game is so good like so good oh my gosh you
and 31 percent of players agreed to cut and visit gal
You win 73% of players for Gabe and Visigal.
We chose 61% chose Twinkies.
53% Glass the bartender.
97% of players rescued Gollum from himself.
No, wow.
Thank you so much for the 50.
Thank you.
I can fix her.
I think Missigal just needs she needs like a kick in the
butt.
But she's a good she's a good character.
She's a good person and a good character.
Just needs a bit of a kick in the butt.
I could fix her.
But not romance her.
One more detective games.
Love this much.
Wolf Among Us.
Oh yeah!
Yeah yeah!
Chose to go all out against the red ring.
Golem
Nice, next episode, let's go Yeah, her heart's in the right
place She just needs to like Yeah You know
Top 20%
It's this guy I keep seeing this mascot everywhere
I want some cokey I want some cokey Oh my gosh.
One of my favorite things that I used to do was my grandpa
would let me open...
Oh.
Would let me open those and pour them into his coffee.
It was my favorite thing.
Oh, no.
Just a little spiel.
Wait.
It's satisfying opening it.
It is, isn't it?
Oh.
Good morning.
Good morning, meantime.
Oh, excuse me.
I'm through.
Oh!
Kiss?
Safe.
Oh.
Thank you.
That's a...
Oh.
Your lifesaver.
Oh, wait.
That's a little...
It's an Irish coffee?
Maybe?
So cute.
The knot.
in the area boss we don't have any heroes in the area can
you handle things here we're overrun out there and i i just
think i need to get out and oh i should have said just come
back oh my gosh we got you covered i didn't even see that
one until i after the tablet keep an eye on the feed the
tablet wait what do you mean you don't have anyone out there
where's all the
the best but you look like you can use the help ah we can
use whatever you can give good oh oh you're all the way over
there what are we what are we supposed to do
oh is this it what you mean is this it but you know what
time it is sorry i didn't mean it like that thanks for
getting out of bed or whatever you were up to
Are you going to finish your sentence, big man?
Shut up, not I did.
Look, we're short-handed.
We should have the rest of the team trickling in, so we'll
have to make do for now.
Lucky for us, we got the best three heroes on the roster.
Yeah, we do.
Actually, I have some pretty good people on the roster,
so...
Do you see all now?
I don't know if I'm making that difference right now.
okay all right lock in team lock in oh wow oh oh my god
jumping jesus red ring swarming all over the city first
things first yes half the team is missing let's fix that
immediately next la is on fire okay we'll work on that ball
and can sweep this yeah ring is oozing out of every crack in
the city damn that's a lot of things it is a lot of things
but nothing we can't handle so i need focus shit's only
gonna get worse if you don't you with me yeah okay oh boy
boy boy boy what's this one red rings at crypto night
doppel's out there already but there's too many even for him
send them still ready to rock baby what's here isn't that
what we pay sdn for we're not evacuating convince the mayor
to call for evacuation oh uh i think so Yeah, what?
Okay.
There's a suspicious package outside of City Hall.
Please send someone to investigate.
We need someone smarter.
Hold on.
Big claws.
Track.
Oh, boy.
Punch-up is not good for any of these.
Wait, this might be good!
Wait, what's this one again?
Because... Oh, wait.
This is the bomb.
Oh.
He could finally get injured if he gets blown up, right?
Which one would hurt him?
I need my blood oozing out his nose.
He won't fail.
Punch the bomb.
Okay, we'll do the bomb.
I think that one's the...
I think you guys are right.
That one's like the one that will...
Yeah.
Be a higher chance.
I punched the bomb.
Oh.
Robert.
That bar on the top left, that's Torrance.
Or what's left of it.
We need to stop the Red Ring before they wipe us off the
map.
Alright, everyone.
You should get live updates on the state of the city.
Let's kick some Red Ring ass.
Oh!
That doesn't seem so good.
Wait, so does it need to go stay up?
That's like a lifeline?
Nice.
Oh, achieved the perfect dispatch with only one hero.
I got an achievement for that.
Very cool.
Um, let's see.
Okay, so it's HP.
Okay, so it does need to stay up.
Uh, I'm gonna go for intellect again.
And they're resting.
That should be able to be good.
Oh, this is surprisingly high.
God damn it!
Alright, what was this one?
I just released an experiment from containment.
It's a...
a big thing with claws track it down we have to be fast i
don't have anyone fast
golem oh what's it gonna be this time yang welcome to my
push-up thank you all right someone's tracker is freaking
out what was it what is it we'll do that hacking thing that
you do what is it i'm hacking
golem solo yeah if he gets injured i'm gonna scream oh I
don't like it oh shoot oh okay it's real oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh shoot you've got to be
kidding me it's so long uh if only there if only I could
loop him but I I can't!
Oh my gosh, this is crazy.
Um...
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I don't think I'm gonna make this one, you guys.
Try the other one.
I...
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Ah!
Oh!
Are you serious?
Uh-oh, this is bad.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Oh shoot!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, okay.
Yes, oh.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's, everything's fine.
Everything's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, it's this thing again.
Warmer.
There we go.
Oh.
Scary.
That was close.
It was flambé.
Yay!
We got flambé.
What are you doing?
Wait, what is he doing?
Holy cow.
Don't.
Be careful.
We don't know what's going on in the refinery.
what's happening to flumbay what the are we waiting for
flumbay is going to explode i'm just gonna send you're done
for what is this the mayor is refusing to listen to reason
could you perhaps lend a hand okay yeah go i'm sorry i'm
late punch up punch up solo oh i could have oh not much just
the end of the world good to know i reckon we're gonna try
and put a stop to that Get your ass in gear, babe.
We're putting in some mad OT.
I could have really used you like two seconds ago.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Oh, I have, let's see, Prism.
I don't really have it.
I don't want to just, like, use...
I'm putting it in intellect.
Smarter.
It's okay.
I think it'll be all right.
Let's see what's going on here.
Flambé, okay.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, oh, it was so close.
I think I'm going to use my head.
Ah!
We got it!
Punch-up doesn't receive any debuffs or injuries.
He cannot be downed.
Oh, wait, no, we didn't!
We didn't!
Okay.
Requesting backup.
We've got several 487s at the mall.
Civilians, not Red Ring.
I want...
Is this going down fast?
Uh, fast enough.
Or I don't think I'll be able...
I can at least heal...
Oh, I got these dickheads.
I can heal him.
At least.
Guess what?
Swiftly.
Wait.
Make up your mind.
There we go.
We can at least heal him.
Pain and gain.
There we go.
That's a hell of a deal.
Oh, what's happening?
Oh, water boy!
Shit.
Signal split.
Can't look for them at the same time.
Gotta pick one to track first.
Water boy.
Where's Waterboy?
Waterboy?
Where's... Waterboy.
Waterboy's come a long way, but he can't handle this alone.
Come on, Waterboy.
Let's go.
We're hacking.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Hang tight, Waterboy.
Oh, okay.
Oh, whoa.
Let me...
Oh, gosh.
As soon as I move.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, gosh.
This is scary.
He's gonna be up there.
No, probably.
Stay with me.
Recalibrating it.
Ah!
Oh, jeez!
Oh, scared me!
Ah!
Is it not in there?
Or...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Out of range.
There's not another thing for me to unlock, though.
Oh, gosh.
Where is it coming from?
Okay.
uh the island how am i supposed to jump over there oh come
on wait unless i did this open no there's not another thing
oh i'm so stupid okay just kidding oh my god i hate okay
yeah we can juke it a little bit got him got him Okay.
I was like, wait a second.
Only stressing a little bit.
I am getting stressed out.
I'm stressed out too.
I'm stressed.
Yay.
And that's how we do it down under.
Let's get you.
Oh my gosh.
She's actually...
Look at that.
Complete symmetry.
Waterboy, what's happening?
Did they put Waterboy on a train?
What?
He's on a train being sent out of town.
Gotta get there fast.
Okay, hold on.
What's this one?
There's a bomb downtown.
We need someone to defuse it immediately.
Defuse the bomb.
We gotta use Prism.
You ain't ready for this.
She's smart enough to do it alone.
both.
I feel me.
You weren't injured.
We have time.
Maybe we can send Malevila to heal him too.
I'm going to send him with Malevila so they'll heal.
We just have to...
We need all hands on deck and our trainees are pissed at us.
Oh, I do have a heal item!
Oh my gosh.
I haven't... I even forgot about them.
But I could use it on someone else that, like, I think it's
okay send my level up with flambe and then i could heal
punch up i think that would make more sense
what is this one join sweet talker and reassuring the
trainees that no one should die oh you probably need to go
to this because you're our best talker right now but it's
you're not like our greatest talker hold on wait maybe we
could actually we'll send golem once he's done
that was scary that was scary Okay, all right.
Sen Golem?
New me?
Fucking rocks.
Yeah?
Don't heal Punch-Up.
Oh yeah, Punch-Up can't be down.
You're right.
That was his skill that just unlocked.
Team first.
Does it matter if he's...
Guess what?
Oh yeah, yeah.
Well, yeah.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
Send.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah.
There we go.
Okay.
We're good.
Everything's fine.
What happened?
Uh-oh.
Look, how is Coupe required?
She's not even here.
I don't even have her here.
Oh yeah.
Easy.
Easy peasy.
Everybody's inspired.
It's good.
Alright, we're fine.
Everything's good.
Oh yeah, I could have gotten her back instead of water boy.
But we could get her back after this.
No, like, come on.
There she is.
I need backup now.
She's drowning?
Pull her up?
What?
How?
How did that happen?
I need to send Waterboy.
Hold on.
We're gonna send Waterboy.
He's gonna be the best bet ever.
She's got time.
You're only drowning.
Okay, she doesn't have time.
I'm scared.
You got this punch up.
Maybe Flambé actually would do it.
I need it.
Back up now.
What the fuck did they take her there?
coffee in case I need it for like an emergency if a lot of
things start, you know, like popping up all at once.
I think this is enough, right?
Or does it need more vigor?
Oh, I think this is fine.
You can use coffee multiple times in these shifts.
You can?
Since I only have one, though.
Okay, I'll just use it on Water Boy.
It'd be so good.
Ready for to go do more work.
Go do it.
Look, it's my favorite team in fire and water.
Fire and water.
There he goes.
A little slow.
It's actually quite slow.
Ring will soon be the dead ring.
All right, King's all here.
Some of you in worse shape than others.
He didn't even get there.
Shit.
He doesn't look that bad.
I'm sober yet.
Oh, uh-oh, here we go.
Alright, everybody.
Oh.
Oh, Phamama-Man.
Give me one second.
Is he gonna...
Phamama-Man?
Uh, fuck.
What's your name?
Phamama-Man?
Hey, Phamama-Man.
No, I'm good.
I thought we talked about the melons.
Unfortunately, I signed up for the monthly melon
subscription.
Wait, where can...
Is that as real?
Phamama-Man.
it 11 months renee that's uh that's great you like saving so
how about you help save the fucking city it does sound
better than 10 of 822 dollars holy that's a lot of money
look it doesn't matter galen can you just help him get into
the hero pool yes sir yes sir okay no those are still good
those are still good melons that sounds not worth it Okay,
we're gonna...
Oh, we get to play with him.
His name is Phenomenal Man.
Wait, I can't say it.
His name is Phenomenal.
I thought it was Phenomenal Man.
Wait.
You may call me Phenomenal.
Phenomenal.
That is my name.
Phenomenal Man.
Big fan.
I'm a big Phenomenal man fan.
Is that the wet janitor who shakes fire?
Mama ma'am!
Wait, I've been calling him that this whole time!
He knows who I am!
Waterboy's very excited to work with you.
Phenomenal.
Oh my gosh, we actually get to work!
Oh geez, okay.
The cult of Chad is using the chaos to summon their god
through human sacrifice.
The cult of Chad.
Wait, we gotta save, or not save, we gotta send Malevolu.
Oh, his stats are...
Okay.
I want to send her though.
Could be worse, I guess.
That's the spirit.
What's her?
Her powers again?
Oh, let's just heal.
Oh, uh, creates a portal.
Stats are good.
Wait, we can find- He's so sad!
For Mama Man, flies to all locations, greatly reducing
travel time.
Okay.
Let's just call him Melon Man.
Melon Man!
Wait, Min, what's on your mind?
He's so sad.
Let's just send the two of them, I think they got it.
Get me on my jet right now.
Utopia.
Thank you for your streams.
I've been feeling down lately, but thanks to you, feel
better.
Thank you, Vito.
Thank you, Rick!
I'm glad I could help in any way.
Escort.
What would be escorting?
Protector?
I think probably...
I think Golem can one-man this.
Stadium's on fire.
We're suspecting explosives.
We need backup.
Stadium's in flames.
Put out the fires.
All right, Waterboy.
It's all...
This is a...
Wow.
It's all you.
It's all...
You.
It's all you.
It's literally him.
I don't...
What's his quirk?
Or his power?
No.
He didn't assign himself.
Oh, because I have...
I have been sending him.
And then...
Oh, he no longer is...
Oh, that's right.
That's right.
I forgot that he doesn't do that anymore.
He will heal.
So it doesn't really help, honestly.
he can't just he just can't do it quickly but i think it'd
be really good i could have him heal coupe actually now that
i think about it coupe is injured you can't really tell
though i could have her heal she's hurt right that's why she
has like her her she's not oh I thought that's why her
mascara was running, unless she's always been like that.
Oh, just kidding.
Everyone got healed in the cutscene.
Lucky them?
Shit.
The DTLA branch are all accusing each other of being red
ring spies.
Uh-oh.
Um...
Prism, I think you've got this.
Or...
Prism?
Flambé and Prism, maybe.
I love a symmetrical stage picker.
Yeah, let's do the two of them.
And then...
Superhero backup requested.
Giant monster on the beach.
It's tearing the pier apart.
Take down the Kaiju.
Evacuate.
Oh no, Gollum's busy.
We can wait a little bit of time.
Maybe we can get for Mama Man and, you know...
Oh yeah.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Hamster!
You are certified for that forklift, alright?
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
I got a hack there.
Wait, okay, before I hack.
Alright.
Water boy?
What?
What's happening?
You're gonna work with your... Actually, should I send in
the...
Okay, hold on.
You're not going to work with your hero.
I'm sorry.
Close your eyes.
Your hero is going to the Kaidu.
I think honestly he could solo it.
Did you know that every time the city grows, it becomes
larger?
He'll work with his Oshi eventually.
This starts throwing punches.
Rally against the real enemy.
I think that is charisma.
So we would...
that oh yeah easy easy
okay all right the university security system was triggered
and we've got students locked inside oh difficulty hi scary
oh my goodness oh god lee oh okay sorry i always forget that
these are
Left left, right up.
Left left right up left left right up left left right up.
Timer was going kind of fast before.
Oh.
Wait.
wait wait oh shoot oh dang it i think i need this one
instead ah okay
okay oh wait i guess i well i do need okay yeah i need this
maybe doesn't matter yeah i do need it uh shoot let's go
back for the other oh my gosh ah okay Okay, we got this, we
got this, we go.
Oh, I don't got this.
Oh, shoot.
Ah, I don't got this.
I went the wrong heckin' way.
Okay, we got this.
Good thing there's nothing chasing after me.
It'd be pretty bad.
Let her cook.
The students have been rescued.
Okay.
Alright.
What's going on?
The Kaiju has a red ring collar around its neck.
They must be controlling it.
I think either.
We can either attack it or break it.
Break the collar!
Uh oh.
We did not make it.
There's no time for this.
Oopsie.
He's so sad.
Go home.
Oh, hold.
Dang it.
Oh, no.
Mama man.
Uh, great.
High call volume.
He's really depressed.
Because fuck us, right?
Fucking couch.
So Mama man needs only two seconds of rest.
However, if any call fails or misses, he will be depressed
and need 45 seconds of rest.
Oh, he's depressed right now.
Hey, uh, seeing this shit?
What is that?
is that whatever it is it sounds like more shit oh that
doesn't oh my god yo z team been a while miss me oh sonar
brought red ring back up a lot of red ring backup sonar what
the actual fuck guess what blazer i'm off the diet plan
shroud lets me eat whoever i want whoever yeah that's not
the flex you think it is don't worry you and me always gave
him indigestion we need to take sonar down cannibalism the
red ring will scramble well here's that cannibalism she's a
batman little little oh we can attack him red ring zooming
out tech like it's candy there's a ton of gangs wreaking
havoc down here bust the torrents towers secure the red ring
tech okay okay what if i let them work together now he's
part human i think it still counts true matter.
Blazer can't fight her own battles anymore.
Oh.
Whoa, what's happening?
Cool.
Interrogate Sonar's crew.
Intimidate Sonar's crew.
Subjugate the cult Sonar's crew.
Success will reduce Sonar's forces.
He looks so sad.
If I did this, well, it's not enough to interrogate, maybe.
Water boy.
This could be it.
We don't have enough...
Wait, we don't have enough charisma.
I don't think we have enough charisma.
A valuable lesson in uncertainty.
I wonder if Coupe and Punch-Up would be better.
Wait, she needs to be...
She needs to be the second slot.
There.
Swift is the knight.
Sharp is my knight.
I think they would be better.
Let's just try them.
We'll have them work.
Don't worry.
We'll have them work together.
That's rich.
Diffuse the bomb.
If you are sure, I'm willing.
No, it's this one.
It's this one.
These two.
They'll do it.
Crime is much easier to stop.
And he got healed!
It's good.
I think Prism can...
Let's go, bitches.
Can solo this one.
It's just a fuse it.
Oh, dang.
I didn't know we had it like that.
Red rings put up a roadblock.
Destroy the roadblock.
Brace yourself for oncoming fire.
I think Golem can solo this.
Honestly, we healed his heart.
We healed his heart.
I think Golem can solo this.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, easy.
Oh, wow.
Oh, golly.
For Mamaman is already ready to...
I understand there are higher priorities for SDN at this
moment.
Vanderstank's girlfriend is demanding a coffee from Santa
Monica be brought to Vanco.
Okay, hold on.
Robert, got any Z-teamers nearby?
I need help with evacuation.
Evacuation.
can do the other.
I feel like Famama Man can do that mission.
We've got another gang out here with Red Ring Tech.
Is this coffee of dire importance?
I think he could do it.
He's also like our fastest guy and he doesn't need to so
whatever.
Um...
I'm gonna send...
Help Pom Pom.
Pom Pom.
Carry civilians that cannot move themselves.
I feel like I need to send both of them.
I feel like...
If he fails at coffee, I swear...
Hold on, they're kind of...
slow we might be able to let's see how this is going oh my
god oh my god we killed it that was like as close as you
could have possibly gotten that's crazy that's crazy no no
no no oh that was so Nice!
And we did it?
Okay.
Can you imagine?
Let's see.
Mobility?
I do need some more mobile.
Well, I have Flambé.
It's mobile.
If I'm a man, it's pretty mobile too.
But it would be nice to have that area kind of covered,
right?
Like just a little bit more of a triangle.
I say so.
I think so.
It's an important little bit, I'd say.
Okay.
Alright, we need to do those other two.
Oh!
Oh, that was so close!
Oh my goodness gracious!
That was scary.
Okay, alright, we need to do these two.
Hey, he's moving.
That's kinda not good.
Alright, for Mamma Man, Water boy!
Can I?
Am I?
It's up to you too.
All right.
And then these two...
What's Malevolah's powers again?
Oh.
She just heals.
That's right.
Let me fry somebody, please.
My money's on Voiza.
I guess Waterboy and Malevolah would have had their synergy
thing going on, but I want him to be with his Oshi.
I want him to be with his Oshi.
That's a way of my sweet.
Thanks.
like what's the bet send coupe right now this is payback for
the handcuffs okay i'll send coupe it's coupe a golem wait
that'd be huge wait this would be so good sending the press
superhero into battle like it's even killing oh yeah i think
we got this uh
I'm the alpha.
I hate the shit you ever said.
Oh, oh, oh, that was so scary.
I'm the alpha.
Civilians escorted, baby.
Nice, malevola, let's go.
Watch me burn.
More stuff, okay.
That was gross to hear.
I didn't like it at all.
Gang arrested.
Okay, all right, hold on.
before we sent her out.
Wait, it's gonna disrupt our...
No!
It's gonna disrupt our everything!
We'll go with mobility.
Probably.
No!
It's straight in the middle though.
Just don't upgrade.
Get it to five all?
Okay, we'll get it to five all.
Alright, let's see what we got going on here.
the roadblocks weaken the bridge guess we'll just have to
hold it up ourselves hurry before it collapses lend your
strength to oh everybody's resting okay we'll let them rest
what is this one found the distributor of the red ring tech
it's mr fister mr fister defeat
mr fister the red ring lieutenant with attack enhancement mr
fister no no one's in danger but we've paid good money for
this service what else could possibly be keeping you new
gated community has been set ablaze no civilians are in
danger okay we can still we can still get flambe at least
maybe even malevolah oh oh boy okay never mind this one
before it collapses those are fastest people malevolah wait
no flambe oh my gosh flambe is crazy Wait, he's got the
strength!
Wait, is it- oh wait, is it combat or vigor though?
Wait, hold on.
I still get confused about them.
Because in my brain, they're the same thing.
You have to be strong to have combat.
It is vigor, isn't it?
Dang it.
We could do this- Holy moly.
It's kind of overkill.
Let's do...
Wait, let's...
For Mamamam Sholo.
Or...
Holy fucking shit.
I think we... I guess he's not...
He's... He needs to be healed.
Still on my feet.
Let's do this.
Let's do this one.
Yeah, yeah, this should be good.
Kimmy just got a whole lot more fun.
There we go.
What's going on here?
B!
He doesn't need healing, but his stats are lower because of
it, no?
Yeah, and it does buff Malevola.
So true.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Uh, attack in it.
It doesn't reach.
His stats can't get low.
What?
Am I crazy?
Why was it red then?
Why was his thing red then?
Oh.
Gosh.
Okay, you guys can't blame me, though.
I just unlocked it literally like 20 minutes ago, okay?
Okay.
I just unlocked it like 20 minutes ago.
I can't blame you.
Oh my gosh, there's so much happening.
This one.
Mr. Fister, we gotta get this guy.
I'm sending you in.
For Mamma Man.
Uh.
So close.
Alright.
Very good.
I'm not blaming.
Thank you.
Oh, this place.
I'm just...
What?
You know what?
Water boy?
You got this, solo.
Red ring creep Smile Moore took over the radio station.
She's trying to brainwash the citizens!
With her red ring implant, Smile Moore is able to convince
her enemies of anything.
Only someone with strong mental fortitude.
Let's wait for Kupai.
Maybe?
Or is it...
It says...
What the fuck?
Why is the neighborhood watch mobilizing against the red
ring?
Flambé.
Protect the well-meaning, but defenseless and weak civilians
against their overpowered enhanced opponents.
Not the weak and defenseless civilians!
I think Flambé has to go in here, but I'm scared that it's a
vigor thing and not a combat thing.
No, it must be a combat thing.
Combat and vigor.
I don't want to send call me a bogo bitch hmm protect sounds
like vigor right hmm this should be enough though it should
be good I'll just send them both finally I was getting sick
of flying over the same boarding holdings now I've got I was
scared for a second.
I was like, wait a second.
I forgot that it was the first.
Okay, you.
Hey, that red-ring creeps Smile Moore took over the radio
station.
She's trying to brainwash the citizens.
All right, we're going to say in the coupe.
Wait, can I sign coupe?
For Bamaman is not really with a strong mental fortitude,
but that...
Okay, let's see what we got going on.
Close your eyes.
You're not going to like what you see anyway.
Why do I even need to send him?
But I think...
I think it needs more...
Just a little more of the charisma.
Oh, Coupe does have retry, you're so right!
Is there... what's her other...
Graceful.
The other one is mobility.
Yeah, we'll just do this one then.
Okay, we'll just try.
I'll give her something to smile about.
I think he's got this.
I never doubted.
I never doubted for even a second.
Civilians are headed towards their doom!
There's no way they can handle the red ring!
Aid them in the fight.
Water goat.
He's too good.
Honestly, we could do a couple of these.
We could move them to say, I'll aid them.
Fight, fight, fight, fight, fight, fight.
Easy.
Fight, fight, fight!
You're my VIP.
Shit, you're mine too.
Okay, we can't fight Batman yet again.
Oh, oh.
Is that really how it went?
Are you sure?
No, no, please!
Oh my god!
Oh this is... Oh no!
Oucha.
Wait, why is he depressed?
Oh, because...
We gotta go solo Dolo when they count the most.
We're just... failing slower.
That's how I feel, bruh.
They got a straight team, bruh.
Hitting us everywhere.
Can't get a win no kind of win.
You're right.
Hey, listen up.
This isn't working.
This is what they want.
Okay, they send us to every corner of the city spreading us
then forcing us to travel back and forth No more coming back
to base between calls.
Okay, we stay out for as long as we can So your plan is for
us to get more tired than we already are Are you sure it
gets your butt handed to us?
Oh, so embarrassing So we need to switch it up be less
predictable z team what happens today will live on and Head
in first battle we break be the one who you say some
inspiring shit or try to at least Hi.
Everybody.
That looks like when you're in a Discord and it says
everyone is typing at once.
Just want to talk.
Everyone.
Several people are typing.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Who do I have here?
Oh, I almost did not.
Level.
Wait.
It's not you.
It's Coupé.
Dug.
We're gonna do more charisma.
Because that really put us out.
I love Flambé.
I love the inspiring stuff he says.
Yeah?
Blazer, I'm assuming he's talking about.
About.
Oh, wait.
We could do.
You sure, bro?
What the fuck is going on?
No, we can't.
We can't.
I'm still here if you need me.
No, we can't.
You're not going to like what you see anyway.
Wait.
Guess what?
No.
Oh, wait.
That's not who I meant to put in.
Can I?
Am I ready for this?
Everybody's too smart.
But we can do Flambé and Malevilla.
Let's rip him up.
I think that'll be good.
Uh.
Okay, good doc.
Yo, Ravi.
I want my tie back.
so i can you know choke you with it nope nope nope rescue
all the civilians
flambe and flamberman are your hymbo go to hymbo's destroy
the red ring reach the civilians before tomatowns do i think
of flamberman villains abound if you are sure i'm willing If
you are sure...
Sharp as the knight.
Sharp as my knife.
I'm willing.
I think I'll do this one instead of Flamama Man.
Much obliged.
You're welcome.
Z team's gonna stop us?
That's rich.
That's evil.
It goes all the way to that X corner.
Wait, you're not allowed to touch that.
Is she okay?
Wait, beefcake?
Didn't we fight her last week?
Beef?
She was the one attacking the Frigo's base.
Convince beefcake to surrender peacefully?
I think Prism can solo this.
Maybe.
Probably.
We gotta fight this guy again.
water boy you want water boy okay i'm away from do finish
resting up
oh oh what the fuck is this i've got you wait a second what
slumming it with a phoenix program oh damn blazer's here i
see you in trouble and i just can't help myself well that's
great because deep ship pretty much constantly i was not
expecting to see my former lover at a time like this oh this
is so awkward but she like totally helped us i think we were
still gonna make it but um thank you blonde what's her stats
oh yeah oh what holy cow she's so good
flies all heroes that pass through blazers radiant like it a
protective shield that the Spends them against one injury?
Oh my god.
Age redacted.
God, she's old.
Yeah!
Several brand deals and film commercials in Europe.
Oh my god.
5-11.
Okay, what are we doing?
Yo, we've got to play.
but we need backup.
We could actually turn this around.
Automatons are headed for the city.
Construct a trap to help dwindle their numbers.
We need somebody smart.
I have nobody smart.
We'll wait for Coupé.
But we also gotta fight this guy.
Wait, what's this right here?
I've always wanted to take over a city.
It was on my vision board.
Oh my god!
Is it because I was...
was too slow with sonar?
The age of redacted is in demand.
So true!
Praise the sun!
It was?
Dang.
Okay, okay.
We gotta fight him then.
Oh no, they got hurt!
Oh no, they got hurt.
Uh-oh.
Uh, that's not good.
Um, let's see.
Um, Malevilla can...
Um, okay.
I was gonna send Waterboy, but...
But that's what he said to do.
Okay, we can send Waterboy still.
Waterboy can heal Malevilla.
What's happening?
Remains strong through his attacks.
Dodge has dive bombs.
They don't really have much combat.
That's the thing.
Sweating again.
Am I?
It doesn't change anything.
Holy cow.
Flambe?
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, we can...
We'll do that instead because, uh...
Yeah.
He'll still heal him.
Oh, that's nice.
Okay.
And Coupe?
You are so much.
You're not gonna like what you see anyway.
I think she could do it.
Level up for the heal.
Coupe is not down.
Coupe is not her.
Her and Blaze, I think that would be like a total waste of
Blaze.
Is Malevolet heal herself?
No.
She doesn't heal herself.
At least she hasn't in the past.
I could try.
I'll try it.
Yeah, see?
She doesn't heal herself.
Oh, I'm escaping on the USS Iowa.
Seize them before they get away.
What if I put him with Blonde Blazer?
Wouldn't that be so awkward?
Wouldn't that be like So awkward.
We can do this.
Ah, laser.
You're looking well.
Same to you, Phenomenon.
I still have your hairbrush.
I've been using it to comb my mustache.
Oh, why don't you just keep that then?
Oh, gross.
The automatons are almost there, we need to think fast.
Get smart!
Aw, I should have sent him.
What is their ship?
If they are a fire and water.
My tail's wagging, I swear.
All right, wait, what is, what is she, what is Prism doing?
She's been over there for.
Help!
We're trapped on the bridge!
Oh geez!
Uh oh!
Um, collapsing, rescue the civilians before the bridge
collapses.
Oh, um, hold on, guys.
Steamy boys.
Steam?
Crazy.
Crazy work.
Okay, Prism's back in business.
Oh, I thought she was faster.
Oh, Coupa is almost done.
We could do...
Okay, this is going to be like crazy overkill.
Praiseful, but deadly.
Because I want...
I want to heal.
I want to heal Prism.
What I could try and do is get Waterboy with Malevola and
Prism and have the three of them heal.
Oh, Mamma Man.
Oh, my God.
It's crazy.
It's so overkill.
Yeah, yeah.
Stop.
Stop it right now.
Yeah.
Nice.
We might just pull this.
off come on you heard the man one last push yeah i was gonna
say i think we just need to get him one more time to the
goddamn city after this i'll guess no where's blazer here
she is on me here she is give him everything you've got i
mean i could do that i think i want i want blazer and golem
to go together You need everything.
Max it all, max it all!
Nothing beats the original, but this will have to do.
What if I just do this though?
What if I just...
Oh no, we still need a golem.
But then, uh, hold on.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, what am I doing?
There we go, there we go.
Oh, yeah.
I think we've got this, guys.
I'm the alpha.
Time I acted like it.
Why me alpha?
That's the most beta shit you ever said.
Overkill?
It said everything we've got.
I had to give him everything we've got.
My ring stole one of our news copters.
They're firing down at civilians.
Jesus Christ, take that copter out now.
Flambé is good for this.
Pinpoint an appropriate location for landing.
And from...
Waterboy.
Here!
The Dream Team!
This is a...
Wow.
Scary.
The Dream Team!
Steam Boys!
The Steam Team!
Yeah!
Sam from Mamamanto!
Why?
This...
Hold on.
I want to see them do this first.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I think that was about to be a bomb.
Successful defeat Sonar.
Covered the entire graph on a single call.
Hey, great work, team.
Couple more calls and we're...
Uh-oh.
Protected Los Angeles!
Yippee!
Backup generator?
Should already be on.
Chase.
Oh,
he's in the infirmary.
But the backup generator's on, so...
Look at you, you're being a hero.
Oh, beef!
Yeah, what's the procedure for this?
Okay.
All right, take care of him.
Oh.
Fat dog.
Yeah, it was really big.
Oh, I trusted you, Vizzy.
You were wrong for this.
I defended for you.
You fucking put me down.
I didn't do anything.
No, no, I caught you.
I caught you red-handed.
Whoa, whoa, look.
What's going on?
Use your head.
Hey, hey.
The fuck is going on.
She tries to steal your mech suits.
Oh, fuck off.
And break my heart, brother.
But Vizzy is a traitor.
She played all of us.
That's not what I was doing.
I'm trying to help you.
I trust her.
I believe her, though.
Never again.
No, wait, wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Does stand there and does not stand there.
Oh, shit.
is that the real I trust her though she bring the keys to
steal the car but I stop her you fucking idiots you need me
you brought the Astral Pulse you already do enough you don't
know what's coming what are you talking about?
yeah what are you talking about?
uh oh she bring them here
yeah she should probably elaborate you know yeah it would be
really good if she were to be like i'm on your side here's
everything i know oh my god you know what this guy's so
annoying i'm glad that he went back to being a villain so i
can punch this shit out of him you helped enough i going no
call my girlfriend we need to get blonde blazer here yeah
call her she'll know what to do that's not gonna work they
have jammers up you're not gonna be able to call out or call
in that's why this place isn't already swarming with heroes
you sure a lot about the plan for someone not involved look
they tried to recruit me of course they did but i said no
bullshit watch her i go get the power back on i moved their
mecha man suit to the rec room here take this is that taser
oh shoot we're fighting the red ring right i'm not walking
home from yoga all i got brother hey don't listen to her
kind of okay you keep her tied up I believe her though.
I believe her.
I got some pepper spray you can borrow if that's not enough.
Oh no!
Kitty!
Tell us everything you know!
Why won't you...
Mr. Whiskey, is that his name?
Alright, untie me.
What?
Why are you looking- You didn't lie to me?
But you didn't- tell me the truth.
Ooh.
I'd love to sit here and explain.
Yeah, why didn't you tell me?
But a pile of red-ring assholes are streaming into the
building right now.
I just don't understand why you wouldn't tell me.
Yeah.
I was worried Shroud would come after you.
Well, he did.
So if I gave it to you, he'd have the pulse right now.
I was...
I was trying to protect you.
Yeah.
Well, the internal bleeding I've got from your old boss
isn't making me feel...
I trust her blood.
Really?
Thumbstick.
What?
It's his name.
Because he sticks you with...
They're all fucking idiots, Robert, but they're dangerous.
I'm not fucking around.
Untie me.
He looks stupid, but he is a killer.
You don't have powers.
You need my help.
Just let me help.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I want to do it alone so bad, but I'm kind of tired
because I don't think I'll live.
I want to do it alone so bad.
and cut you loose, but his toolboxes are locked.
What did he do that for?
Oh, I fucking wonder, Vizzy.
Why would he lock up his tools around invisible criminal
thieves?
Robert.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh, great.
Good.
Are we in kindergarten?
You doing something alone is a death sentence.
But I believe in myself!
I believe in myself!
They have guns actually though.
And we have scissors, safety scissors.
So, and a...
And a two scissors.
Creepy.
Oh.
Dang it, I thought that was gonna be a...
QTE.
Hold it in, dude.
Hold it in.
Oh!
Why would you even need the keycard for this stupid shit?
Get this place.
I like
how they're censoring his booty.
Three, two.
Oh, come on.
Let me have my moment.
That makes me mad.
oh nice job nice uh nice job gross why are his nuts out oh
thought that was normal you might helping him why would you
creakle cut your balls or your zipper if you don't have what
are you asking me wait what just put his dick away feels
like the dignified thing to do dignified for who i know the
guy a little and it's bad enough uh you do it i'm not gonna
do it you do it yeah if you want to yeah if you want jesus
if you wanted him to be have a dignified death then you do
it I gotta do it.
Eww!
Doesn't even bother me.
I'm not gonna do it.
You wanted to have the dignified death.
Alright, go get your suit.
Wait, shouldn't we stick together?
Oh my god.
The game just saved.
Oh yeah, punch him!
Oh, not- wow, he folded like paper.
Crazy.
Oh, it took was one punch.
Oh, my God.
Oh, dang.
Robert.
Crazy.
Make a man.
Oh, he's saving it, though.
It's kind of smart.
Yeah, broid.
That jumping punch is called super mad.
It's Superman.
It's crazy.
Ho!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
You thought he'd never be Mecca Man again!
Oh, this is the premium package.
Roy, you really outdid yourself.
Mecca again.
Just done riding a bike, huh?
Yeah!
We can handle these guys.
No problem.
This is great.
Oh, and this guy again.
Obviously, the suit doesn't work without the Astral Pulse,
so it is really nice of you to bring it to us.
Wait, he can use the other Astral Pulse.
There's like a fake.
All he has to do is take off the sticker, and then Shroud
will think that he has the Astral Pulse.
And all your friends.
That freaked out, fuck you are!
right sure because it looks like this guy's arms are killing
me or just give us the pulse and we'll let you live with
broken broken arms of course both arms each each one gets
okay we see the casts you're making it weird you're making
it weird where shroud that is that is that what you're
asking yeah that's what i said right What the fuck am I
waiting for?
Okay, we're good.
Crazy, right?
It's like real big, but super quiet.
So cool.
So fucking cool!
Oh my god!
It's freaky!
A weapon to survive!
I need to help me build a mech if I help to build Astral
Pulse.
Poor 14x player.
That's what this is all about.
You need it to power your stupid spider shit.
It's not stupid.
Come on, kid.
It was in the post to power a Mac.
It's like plugging your cell phone into a nuclear reactor.
No.
Have we skipped this part?
I think I like Shroud, though.
Can we just skip this part?
I don't need to know what you would have done if I didn't
stop it.
Which I'm about to do.
Oh.
Oh, they don't like that.
I hate toxic.
He's so annoying.
I know that's literally how he's meant to be.
But he's just so annoying.
Minto is so effin' cool.
Ah, Missile Fury!
Oh gosh, I can't even say it right.
Oh!
You are right, brother!
Flurry!
Like, yeah, like a Mick Flurry!
Cluster bombs!
And whop!
Is it like predicting all of his moves?
Because that's pretty much it.
We tried yet.
Or is this just the warm-up round?
Yeah, that's not good.
Oh my god.
destroyed.
Still got that new car shine.
How do you breathe in there with all that smoke?
Plug the controller into the second floor.
My calculations are just showing up 30 seconds ago.
Sorry.
Disappoint.
Two up.
Freaky.
I can tell you a boring life is without surprises.
Well, then it's a good thing.
I can't even predict what these idiots are gonna do.
My team!
They're all stupid!
They're unpredictable!
What the fuck?
When did she learn that?
Is that Prism's second power that I didn't unlock?
Oh wait, no!
It's just her first power because she duplicates!
Oh my god.
Wow!
Yeah!
Yeah, get mudded.
Oh, oh, oh.
The outcome is the same.
Ah, I'm
part of the action, guys.
He's like a magic cart personified.
It's so good.
The goat.
The Z team.
Whoa, whoa!
Malevolah.
So cool.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my gosh.
No!
I, I, I, well, I did kind of do that quick time event kind
of.
I'm part of the action.
From Mammaman!
I hope my saving you from...
Collision was appropriate.
It was phenomenal.
Wait, they're not gonna get back together.
Please say no.
Wait.
What if he got stolen?
Or if she stole her from me?
Oh, great.
Well, I'll just go then.
Miss a bitch.
Woo!
We never finished our dance.
Get in the chair.
No!
I got the guy for you Oh wow You really think this little
fucking Oh my god he's gonna do his Punch in the crotch Yeah
See ya Because it's been out this whole time Oh we don't
even get to watch it happen
It looks like the The little what's it called The dwarves
from From I see you Metal Gear.
And I hated fighting those two.
Whoa.
Robert, this isn't working.
He knows our next move before we do.
Yeah, the dwarf geckos.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Robert Robertson returned.
I fucking warned you that cutting me was a big mistake,
Bunko.
What?
I guess you're probably realizing that right about now, huh?
over me you're actually so dumb dude you know she was
stealing toilet paper from the office by the looks of things
I made the right decision yeah stupid sonar will remember
that mom's home hey we're your friends please this isn't you
help us stop shroud and earn your spot back on the Z team
you could or you could keep being a little baby here in the
dark oh do you miss cooper no i don't think i will because
you know what now i'm on the meat the meat and if you
couldn't appreciate me at my worst you don't deserve me at
my best oh my god please i'm so glad we cut this guy if
these new augment shrouded me up there'd be some pretty
sweet new moves want to see it no i'm sure Yeah, no, not
really.
Back in the action, baby.
Oh, oh.
Oh, my gosh.
Sometimes I don't have enough space to drag my mouse over.
Yeah, but...
skill is shoot oh shoot
six god
is he gonna turn it off
easy yeah
what happens if you fail that qte i wonder
How do you know I was in there?
Scratch in my face.
You hate him because you ain't him, Minto?
No.
I hate him because he's annoying.
She temporarily blinded me.
I'm just gonna set people on fire.
Oh, nice.
Calm down.
It was your weak hand.
You can still jerk off.
Maybe if you grip it with the 7-1, hold it with...
Yeah, you know what?
Fair enough.
Now kill it.
Oh, shoot!
Sorry.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
That's no good.
Wait, okay, I'm paying attention.
I'm in the action.
Wait.
Oh my god, don't shut the door on her!
Oh shit, oh shoot, okay, I'm locked in.
Oh my god.
I can't even tell what's happening because I'm looking out
for QTEs.
I'm not even looking out for the fight scene at all.
Oh shoot, I missed one.
I'm Osu time, for real!
I've never played Osu.
Oh!
Moves!
Uh-oh!
What?
You're the only one I told about my amulet, so I figured he
wouldn't see it coming.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Holy shit.
Look at you.
When did she have the time to do this?
Yeah, look at me.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god!
Wait, what?
The laser always did have a soft spot for helpless losers.
Fuck off.
Oh my god, steamy boys.
Not so good at seeing now, are you?
Sexy no Jutsu!
That's
the theme song!
Not even Shroud understands what is happening with Waterboy.
Oh yeah, Mandy.
Yes, Mandy, yes!
Rainbow Road!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, Super Spirit Bomb.
Is it over?
We fucked them in the face.
Oh my god, hug by Azores.
That's it?
Let's go again.
Anybody want to go again?
dramatic finish you two nice new uh look why what happened I
still look good right like a French soccer player is going
through something stop wait
no when did he get beef track star well that is a surprise
please Elliot put him down
Surely someone could grab him if he fell.
Why is everyone so tense?
Don't worry, I'm not gonna drop him.
Because Trag Blondie there'll just swoop in and catch him.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I'll do whatever you want!
I know he wants it.
I'll do whatever you want.
You're a hero, yeah.
So, why don't you, and only you, fly your father's suit up
here and give me my fucking astral moths oh and if the rest
of you could surrender that'd be helpful not the dog
mm-hmm there he is so predictable come here he is is your
weakness i knew you'd have feelings for blazer who i prefer
as a blonde oh my god nobody asked that you call her
invisigal that you take invisigal under your wing sloppy guy
extra credit that's why we planted her here
yeah she works for us too she gets two paychecks for the
same job and look at her oh she's embarrassed she was so no
all that to say there isn't a thing you can do that i
haven't modeled out and once i have the pulse i won't need
to predict i'll just know so don't fuck around robert not
right now
no she's like taking the real one or something i just want a
fair exchange just don't be an idiot and try to give me the
shitty prototype.
Oh.
I'm a bad person, but I'm a man of my word.
Give me my pulse.
You all hear that?
I've been through all the game theory on this moment a
thousand times.
The game theory.
I'm not steps ahead.
I'm miles.
So...
Two steps ahead.
Don't fucking test me.
Give it both.
What could that be?
what the fuck is this robert you said you wanted the
astropulse you figure it out i gave it to one of those is it
they look fucking identical robert look you're right i came
out smart because you know what i'm not a smart guy so the
only way to keep you from knowing what i don't know i have
any idea what i'm doing which is how i feel all the time but
i trust my gut and i take best guess just like you used to
do before you plugged all those fucking Christmas lights
into your head before you were afraid to make your own
decisions Elliot Elliot maybe we wait till we get home shut
the fuck up
who fuck you you What's wrong with the red?
You want the blue?
It's hard to say which one, if it's the right one or not.
Uh-oh.
He wants the blue juice instead of the red juice.
Okay, so far he's looking to get powerful, but it could mess
up.
That was worth the wait.
what's happening oh whoa everybody else is awesome oh no oh
wowy okay
feel that you fucking fucks I told you I fucking told you
clouds you feel the power I see it now I can see it all whoa
so I guess it was the right one but I don't think so I don't
know Oh.
All right.
Nanomachines.
Fuck.
Wait.
Just a hunch, but I'm starting to think that you guys are
wrong.
Oh, nah.
It's just...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, the nanomachines.
Invisibish.
I just in time Be a deer and help me get this Oh whoa Oh my
god Whoa fuck I see What the fuck That's a matter shroud
didn't see that coming Oh my god Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you're gonna throw it away, right?
There she goes.
She stole your kill.
She died!
She winked at us, though.
Cute.
Ew!
Didn't see that coming.
We failed as a mentor!
What?
Oh my god.
No way.
Why would we fail?
Literally
everybody was saved.
Our team did good!
Shroud was dispatched.
It was a targeted attack by Shroud and those miserable
jerks, the Red Ring.
There's a story out there that Shroud was actually killed by
a former SDN employee.
Care to comment?
That I don't think I can call...
Collaborated?
No, but it is corroborated.
My hymn, though.
I can say that she did us a damn favor because that Shroud
motherfucker had to go.
Oh, shit.
Beef drinks the blood of the enemies.
It's true.
We can break it out.
Shit, that's the only reason I'm talking.
Point the camera over...
These are the real heroes right here.
Yeah, my team!
Yeah!
Does your team have a name?
Uh...
Z team!
You're the best heroes in the whole motherfucking SDN.
Actually, I'm hearing now we can't bleep the curse words.
Reporting live from SDN 12.
Back to the studio.
Punch up barely in the shot, get Mike Wazowski.
Z-team saved the day.
Yay!
You get to return to the Mecha Mans.
Defend SDN.
Couldn't have done it without you.
Seriously.
All the work you put into the suit is what made this
possible.
Nah.
It's not the hard part.
Do you want an explanation for how Vizzy works?
No.
Well, no.
Obviously you can do that stuff too.
I saw you were throwing those red ring fuckers around like
graduation caps.
No joke.
I started to feel bad for them.
It was mesmerizing.
Yep, that was a fun girl for sure.
I don't get some sleep, bruh.
Not a clean-up tomorrow.
Good job, Mecca, man.
Yeah.
Hee hee.
My girl.
Hey, hey, hey.
The bat in the suit?
Yeah, he's with us.
Yeah, that's a founding VP member right there.
No way.
What do you think?
they earn a pardon no is that my call you're the one oh my
god i have to decide again
fine yeah sure why the fuck not hey yeah no they're with us
i i don't have to deal with him anymore so he can join again
it's the end of the game guys i i got to go the entire game
without him
redemption hey so you maybe got an extra one of those I do
actually really one but a good one I wasn't I mean where'd
all the extra beers come from oh there's a ton of booze in
the wreck room that's where they got it I honestly shocked
it hasn't into an issue.
Oh, shit.
No powers.
I got it.
Forced open beers like a normie.
I'm getting drunk like a normie, too.
One beer!
I've had half a beer, and I'm already feeling it.
Half a beer!
What did he just do?
Oh.
So, is that permanent?
Nah, he's borrowing it until we can figure out a different
solution.
He's trying to wash his hands.
Surely is.
That's the one.
Well, looks like he'll enjoy it while it lasts.
I feel so obvious when you look back.
She never bought in, did she?
I think there was a chance at some point.
What do you think Fizzy's gonna do now?
I figured she was kind of a loner, but she took Shroud's
mask.
I just hope she's alright.
I don't hate her, though.
I just hope she's okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, me too.
Any plans tonight?
You're asking me if I have plans for after getting ambushed
by Shroud and the Redman?
Ah, was that too weird a way of asking if you wanted to make
out later?
No.
She wants to make out now!
It was perfect.
Oh.
She wants to make out now!
Now is later!
We kissed on a car!
That's the...
the achievement.
Yippee!
Seriously, when the team's off Monday?
I was just trying to figure that out.
I think you might need to go.
Why?
Why are they so mean to me?
By all means.
Oh my god, I'm getting princess carried by everybody.
I knew when I told you so about Vizzy.
But instead, I'm just gonna try to make you throw up.
Oh my god, he's taking me to see the stars, the clouds.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Okay.
Hippip.
Hooray.
Let me get a picture.
Hippiporay.
Hooray.
Okay, what's happening?
Okay.
Stop.
Wait, are we taking a picture?
What the fuck is this?
Like a baby.
Oh.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Hey, are you taking a picture?
What's happening?
Mr. Whiskey!
Oh, he doesn't know how to take photos.
Oh, yes he does.
He's- Oh, oh.
Instantly painful, actually.
Oh, no!
Yay!
He's okay!
So, ma'am, ma'am, watching Mandy and Robert make out.
Oh, no!
I didn't even think about that!
Ending, I guess I got like the quote unquote not as not good
ending.
It's a normal ending probably but not bad ending.
Doesn't seem like a bad ending, seems like a normal ending.
But I feel like though, I don't know how the one where it's
good ending with Invisigal, but I feel like this sets up
really nicely for like a sequel.
Spank, thank you!
No bad endings, just hero and anti-hero ending.
Ah, okay, okay.
Yeah, but I feel like it does set it up well, right?
I love Lame Blazo.
It's my first time watching someone play through the game
and it was very fun watching your choices.
Thanks for the streams!
Thank you, Chiyaki!
Thank you!
I'm curious about other routes too now.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Curious, curious.
The game has...
I remember reading somewhere that Aaron Paul said that this
was like...
He's never been in a game before?
Like, he never recorded, like done voice work for a game
before?
But also that like...
This was such a disorienting experience.
We have to know who it is!
Like it's so confusing because you had to re-record certain
things that like Because obviously there's so many choices
It was like I can imagine it being like extreme I probably
would not know at all what the story is of this game It
would be so confusing But yeah Yippee This voice acting was
so good So so good I just love the way you say brief Thanks
for playing Minto Do I say it weird?
Thanks for the fun timing, though.
I hope you check out the other choices sometime.
There's a lot of good interactions and wholesome moments.
Also, don't tell Nimmy you chose Blazer.
Congrats, Minto.
Your playthrough was so much fun to watch.
Love your decisions.
Thank you, Andregos.
Thank you.
Let's see.
You and 61% of players deceive Shroud by giving him both
astral pulses.
curious about the other choices especially if you just give
him the real one outright i feel like maybe i don't know you
and 34 of players watched as a prison gal killed shroud
denying you the chance to exact vengeance or show mercy i
guess you know what that's true i would have killed him but
um it was supposed to be my vengeance not hers you know what
now i'm Now I'm mad at her.
You know what?
I forgot that was the point.
Now I'm mad at her.
She heweed me.
Oh my god!
Kill, steal, dying.
You and 87% of players trust you.
trusted Invisigal and untied her.
That's a pretty strong insult.
Glad you enjoyed the game, Rito.
If they make a sequel, be interested to see which of the
endings they can make.
They make can't...
Right!
I've played through twice myself to see different outcomes.
Had fun watching.
I imagine...
I wonder if they would have it where, like, your save
imports into the second game.
And so it just kind of picks up from where you...
Where you...
You, uh, I neglected her.
What are you?
Five years old?
I'm not your mom.
Oh, my gosh.
Neglected like you're a child?
That's why you fail as a mentor.
You know what?
I was not just a mentor to her.
I was a mentor to the entire team.
And I think I have a higher success rate than failure rate.
Thank you very much.
I think that most of the people on my team were still good.
And she is the only failure.
So, I think I'm doing perfectly fine.
You are leading her to embrace villainy over heroism.
Oh.
You and 32% of players fell for blonde blazer.
Wow.
Not so many.
You and 73% of players defeated Sonar and saved Los Angeles.
You and 26% of players rescued Waterboy first over Goofy.
Nobody believes in him enough.
I don't think that guy failed me ever.
even once.
Mighty fine, dispatching me, Dom.
Way to win the power of not thinking.
Your choices were super fun to see.
As always, you take our breath away.
Actually that power will be super handy for catching your
music out.
Thank you for the stream.
Oh no, thank you for the peek.
Waterboy cannot fail.
He can only be failed.
You and 70% of players welcome Sonar back into the Z team.
How was I supposed- they- I probably would not if it was
just my decision, but because my whole team was just like,
yeah, he's one of us.
I think I wouldn't have done it.
They made it pretty hard to say no.
They really did.
They were like, hey, don't arrest that guy.
He's one of us.
What if I was just like, nah, he can't sit with us?
I got peer pressured into it.
If you failed the battle in dispatching bit, he just gets
jailed.
Oh, he doesn't even get to join you.
The power of peer pressure.
I wanted to try this game, but I don't have the time to play
games now, so I enjoy playing and along with you as if I
were playing with my little sister, just sitting there
watching her play.
No, well, thank you.
I hope it's just as frustrating as watching your little
sister playing a game where you're just like, what are you
doing?
I always wanted to be the little sister.
Wait, I am the little sister.
Sorry, I have an older sister.
But my older sister doesn't care about games or anything.
Your playthrough is great, you made many unique decisions,
others didn't.
Positive, it was very entertaining because of it.
I like causing a little bit of trouble.
You and 57% of players went on the coffee run.
You and 63% of players made invisible, put away thumbsticks.
My boss said hero was from Amaman!
No!
Boy.
Thanks for the fun playthrough.
Inspired me to play a lot of new games in the last year.
Looking forward to this one too.
Thank you!
You got a line from Invisigal in episode 7 I never heard
before.
No way!
See?
It's always fun to have different perspectives of a game.
Yeah, lots of different experiences.
You perform better than 80% of players in today's shift.
I was gaming.
It was funny watching you instantly make choices that most
other people deliberated on.
And every man your robber always kept everyone guessing.
I kept you guys guessing what it was.
say or do next?
Avert!
That's kind of scary.
That's awesome.
Yeah, I'm a little so random.
My boss said, Hero Boss, go!
You perform better than 60% of players across all shifts.
Cool.
That's not bad.
You activated a hero's power 252 times across all shifts.
At least 252 and more to see.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Vizzy put that guy.
My most successful hero was Prism.
Prism is like, I wish I could have seen what her second
skill was, but she was really good.
You barely succeeded on a call six times across all shifts.
You sent the perfect hero for the call eight times.
Most successful shift was episode eight phase two.
Strongest hero is Coupe.
The person I did not fire.
I don't think.
I made a mistake.
That's how you defeat Shroud, though.
It's narratively consistent.
The person that I kept on my team?
Mm-hmm.
The dwarf get-go on the rooftop.
I thought they moved that guy.
That was fun.
I'll be honest, the first episode didn't hook me.
Or, like, the first time I played it, so it was, like, the
first three episodes.
It didn't hook me a ton, but the last playthrough really
hooked me.
I ended up having a lot of fun, though.
Yeah.
Covering up for Sonar like that after he raised half of L.A.
is a bigger part than Arochi Maru got.
I enjoyed it more when, like, the...
I guess, like, the...
I enjoyed playing...
the dispatch part um but uh just like the story I was kind
of like okay this is cool um but once it got like more
serious I liked it a lot
so the cliffhanger is definitely the hook yeah what a solid
like last two episodes it was so fun looking forward to peer
pressure saving you in season 2 great gaming Minto did they
say if there would be one oh my gosh i wonder what do you
ever say talk no jutsu what thousand i keep keeping everyone
guessing there's talks when shroud said six shots man i live
for i think shroud was made for me oh man no why'd you have
to kill him why'd you have to kill him visit gal please we
need him for the sequel he was so cool
matt mercer threw that in there just for you so true and
then i got so caught up in it i didn't even notice the qte
oh my gosh his say i almost said to say you oh wow i'm such
a weeaboo sorry his voice actor matt mercer just killed the
role though so good can't wait for you to for your flambé
covered next karaoke stream which is
he almost killed your dog he wasn't gonna do it I just
needed to give him the thing and I did and he look at it
this way shrouds a ghost now I I liked that he was just like
he's like put some respect on blonde blazer she's one of the
last real superheroes left I'm like yeah he gets it Shroud
and I are like one and the same.
He gets it.
Thank you so much for the fun memories.
Jared, thank you.
He's a villain, not a monster.
He's a really great villain.
But I prefer her, Bruna.
Yeah, he prefers her blonde.
We're like almost kindred spirits.
Oh, so close.
So close.
On side note, I started getting MGS memes shorts on YouTube.
I don't know where last weekend takes, I guess.
Minto, my guide and ghost lie.
I'm sorry, but you cannot do that much math.
had to have a machine do it all for him.
And a mask to calculate it for him.
He literally had a built-in calculator.
So...
My man was consulting ChatGPT every time he needed to do
something.
Is he really that much better than me?
This was good.
This And that's why he picked raw.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
So.
Anyway, this is fun.
This is fun.
Thank you guys for playing Dispatch with me.
What extras we got?
Oh, just our choice stats now.
which we we went through all these just a while ago so yeah
what a funny what a funny situation to give him both though
I liked that I like that idea as soon as we defeated him
though and the fact that we had the second like the
prototype in our in our suit I was like there's no way that
we're not going to utilize this I was like there's so I was
like he has to have something where he's just like not so
fast and I didn't expect to be with the dog, though.
I didn't expect it to be with beef, but that's okay.
It's always the wrong one when you give both?
Hmm?
I love how Maddie got over being handed both.
I know he was so like what?
What?
Shroud could never finish Mind Sweeper.
Fun fact I made up.
It's a fact because it's really...
It's, it's, it wouldn't be a fact if it weren't real.
So it's, it's a, it's real because it's a fact.
Yeah, yeah.
That's a rock fact.
It's a real fact.
It's a, it's a fact because it's a fact, it's real.
Because he claimed to be, he said it's a fact.
Wasn't planning on checking this one out, but your
playthrough was so fun.
I might check it out.
Thanks for another fun series we do.
Thanks, Cap and Troll!
Thank you.
Hot dog.
How did Trout even steal beef?
That's so true.
How did he get the dog?
How did he get beef?
How did he get that guy?
Where was he?
He was in the room with...
with Chase
mysterious chat what the hell is she saying I'm making sense
I'm spitting facts I'm spitting facts Leaf was in on it no
no no sure me Now we're spitting something.
If you want my treasure, you're never going to find it.
I left it somewhere, but no one can find it.
I know I rhymed it with it, but I don't really care.
Because now, I'm going to wash my hair.
It's not in my hair.
it's underneath my pillow why did i tell you that now i
gotta hide it again
oh everybody i have a treasure to go re-hide and find a
really good hiding spot for it thank you so much for this
much have a good day have a good night each